SCHEME WHEN YOU TOLD YOU ABOUT
4,000 BEAGLES WHICH WERE SLATED
TO BE TORTURE FOR NO REAL REASON
AT A RESEARCH FACILITY IN
VIRGINIA TONY FAUCI PURCHASE
DOGS FROM THAT FACILITY FROM THE
WHITE COAST.
FOUND PURCHASE RECORDS THAT
SHOWED ABUSE OF SEVERAL DOGS TO
BE USED IN SEPTIC SHOCK
EXPERIMENTS.
>> Tucker: THEY WERE DENIED
FOOD THEY WERE EVEN ALIVE BY
BUGS IT'S SO DEPRESSING.
MAJOR BREEDING FACILITIES FOR
THE RESEARCH FACILITIES HAVE
BEEN SHUT DOWN THE FIRST BATCH
OF BEAGLES HAVE BEEN SET FREE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT AND JOINED
US TONIGHT WITH AN UPDATE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON SO
THESE BEAGLES ARE NOT GOING TO
BE TORTURED CONGRATULATIONS.
WE ARE CELEBRATING WHAT HABITS
OF THEM NOW?
>> THANK YOU WE ARE CELEBRATING
TUCKER THANKS FOR HAVING ME BACK
ON.
NEXT COME OVER THE NEXT 60 DAYS
OR SO THEY'RE GOING TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES AND
FROM THERE THEY'RE GOING TO
VARIOUS SHELTERS IN VIRGINIA AND
BEYOND.
THE FIRST GROUP WAS RELEASED
YESTERDAY TO THE TUNE OF
APPROXIMATELY 400 THESE ARE
THOUSANDS, AND THOUSANDS OF DOGS
THAT WERE BRED FOR RESEARCH THE
FACILITY HAS BEEN THERE SINCE
1961.
WE ARE JUST THRILLED THAT NOT A
SINGLE ONE OF THESE 4,000
BEAGLES WILL EVER BE TORTURED
AND KILLED IN A LAB.
IT WILL ALL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FIND A LOVING HOME TO FEEL
THE GRASS UNDER THEIR PAWS, THE
SON ARE BACK, PLAY WITH THE TOY,
AND HAVE A NAME THINGS THAT THEY
HAVE NOT HAD THE CHANCE TO
EXPERIENCE THUS FAR.
>> Tucker: WAS SO UPSETTING
ABOUT THE STORY WAS THAT NOBODY
COULD SAY WITH A STRAIGHT FACE
WILL BE STOCKS ARE BEING KILLED
SO KIDS WILL DIE OF CANCER THERE
SEEM TO BE NO JUSTIFIABLE REASON
TO TORTURE THESE DOGS TO DEATH
OR MY MISSING SOMETHING?
>> THIS IS JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG WE ARE THRILLED FOR THE
4,000 DOGS THIS FACILITY WITH
THE SECOND LARGEST PROVIDER OF
DOGS FOR EXPERIMENTS IN THIS
COUNTRY THERE IS A LARGER
FACILITY WHO HAVE BELIEVE IT OR
NOT 21,000 BEAGLES THESE ANIMALS
ARE BRED AND SOLD FOR ABSOLUTELY
POINTLESS PAINFUL EXPERIMENTS IN
OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
BOUGHT DOGS FROM THIS FACILITY
SINCE SEPTEMBER OF 20202020 NIH
IS A CONTRACT FOR LIVE DOGS AT
LEAST THREE CONTRACTS IT IS TIME
FOR THE NIH TO WAKE UP AND
REALIZE IT'S THE 21ST CENTURY
AND MOVE ON TO MODERN NONANIMAL
METHODS.
>> Tucker: ARE JUST SO MUCH
MONEY SLOSHING AROUND THE SYSTEM
HAD TO KEEP IT FLOWING THEY
INVENT EXPERIMENTS THAT BENEFIT
NOBODY SIGN JUST BE TOTALLY
CLEAR ON HER WAY OUT AND ASK HOW
LONG UNTIL THESE DOCS CAN BE
ADOPTED BY PEOPLE WATCHING?
>> THE PLAN FOR TRANSFER WILL
TAKE PLACE OVER THE NEXT 60 DAYS
WE URGE PEOPLE TO JUST KEEP AN
EYE WE'RE JUST SO THRILLED THAT
THEY ARE UNDER INVESTIGATION
PROMPTING THIS DOMINO EFFECT
WHICH RESULTED NOT ONLY IN 74
VIOLATIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE GETTING INVOLVED BUT THE
LIBERATION OF THIS 4,000 DOGS
AND WE HOPE THAT ALL THE CAGES
GET EMPTY NECKS FROM ALL THE
LABORATORIES AND ALL THE
BREEDING FACILITIES.
>> Tucker: THIS SHOW IS
PROBABLY FOR DOG SO WE ALL
CELEBRATING THANKS FOR COMING ON